[Applause]
one question an amazing lineup of CEOs
Founders and experts this is marketing
for the now
[Music]
thank you so much
[Music]
Gary
good afternoon Andrea good afternoon
January it's still January can I say
Happy New Year
I literally literally the two minutes
before we went on here I was sending out
uh hope you have a great year emailed to
a couple friends I've been spoken to in
a while so my rule is you can say happy
New Year until February 1st so I think
we're by the skim of our teeth still
okay all right I'm I'm game for that too
even though people were telling me last
week I had to stop saying it so I'm with
you we're gonna come in hot today we're
talking about some hot takes and we're
super fired up to bring Austin Sprints
up first he has an unbelievable
following Gary He's got 22.5 million
followers combined across Instagram Tick
Tock and YouTube
and I love it because he's all about
mastering the algorithm and
understanding of the platforms so super
fired up to have Austin here from Snowy
Flagstaff take it away awesome thanks
for having me guys
Austin how are you brother I'm doing
good how are you doing Gary too well
before we get into it with Austin I just
want to give some shout outs of people
watching Robert K on LinkedIn what's
good uh Jesse p on Facebook hello Darry
cabrera33 on YouTube hello I'm Alison
love a good on Facebook what's good
let's be very active in the comments
it's great to be with all of you I think
there's a lot of learning and I think we
start off with a bang because Austin
represents something I care about in
marketing which is there's a disconnect
with the people in the trenches in the
dirt actually working the Creative Media
and math strategies of social networks
which are going to be important because
the way that television ads are going to
work is going to be this way because all
of the streaming services their ad
products are much more social media
Centric with targeting and creative than
television
and then you have a lot of the CMOS that
are watching right now that are you know
not because they're bad people they're
in Ivory Towers because they manage so
much and they're not in the dirt
and so Austin I want to really get your
hot takes for 23.
from the dirt like where's the
opportunity for the creators
entrepreneurs small businesses and
Fortune 500 companies from your personal
perspective in amassing what you have
interesting I think uh I think for 2023
one of the biggest things is going to be
Ai and I know uh chat GPT has been
getting really big and I've realized
that I think a lot of creatives are
going to start using chat GPT to
essentially come up with uh ideas and
Concepts or analyze their own videos and
other people's videos to essentially
kind of start to figure out Trends
before they emerge or uh kind of tell
them how to make videos essentially step
by step
so also give people an example because I
think this is exactly right like right
now everyone's like chat gbt it's like
tell a story about 1975 and Mike Tyson's
voice enter and it's like oh my God but
what you're saying and this is
absolutely right from a creative
strategy standpoint you might type in
analyze Mr beasts last five videos and
Austin s's last seven tick tocks tell me
what is aligned in the title and the
copy and the timing they post it enter
and then that artificial intelligence
May spit back something that gives you
some creative Insight that then may
impact the way I make a wine video yes
yeah exactly essentially allows you to
get uh way more analytical on videos
where instead of spending all the time
doing yourself watching each video and
trying to see it for yourself you can
speed up the process by sure putting my
name in and then putting or putting uh
Mr Beast name in or and by the way real
quick I apologize why you've blown up so
much over the last couple years why some
names may not work is the data stops
somewhere around mid-2019 but all the
evolutions going forward of the chat CBT
competitors and I'm sure chat GPT itself
will get more and more and more updated
up to the day yes oh yeah I'm sure and I
think it's up to uh 2021 now so it's
awesome I didn't see that is that is
that right that's awesome yeah and uh
yeah so I mean it's amazing for that but
it's even if uh creators want to kind of
take over the managerial side too they
can also kind of talk to chat GPT on in
terms of how to write messages to these
brands or uh essentially for
communication also do you feel because
I've been on this kick as well and like
I'm reading some of the comments some
people like it's already being used in
our agency a lot of people
you agree with me that a lot of people
are really underestimating how bananas
big this AI thing is going to be yes I
think absolutely yeah
what was your give us let's go right
into the dirt what has been the biggest
like holy [ __ ] that you've typed into
jet that GPT that you were like I cannot
believe this
you want to know what it was for me it
was uh honestly I think it was a talking
with Brands because there's a way that I
was writing the brands when I was
reaching out with them but then it's a
whole other thing when I asked chat GPT
to kind of go over my messages so we can
kind of go deeper with the brands
they're kind of going through the
Brand's website and seeing like what the
Brand's values are and kind of giving me
a quick review preview so I think I
really didn't reach out to monetize what
you do has been upped dramatically
by saying to chat gbd hatch EBT I want
to talk to Wrigley's gum please analyze
their website and social media like like
that kind of game yeah exactly because
then I feel like it gives me a little
bit of a competitive advantage over the
other creators who are just reaching out
there going Wrigley's gum let's work
together because now when I'm reaching
out to them it's uh
James Rossini the OG in the vaynerx
world who's the president runs the Sasha
group just said you know in the chat you
know brand tone of voice which is
exactly right Austin these things go
super fast yeah there's a couple other
minutes what what else is on your radar
what else should people be paying
attention to what else are you excited
about uh let's see last thing I'm really
excited about uh boxing boxing the
influencer realm I think it's going to
be huge this year and I know uh it's
really fun for creators because it's a
really good way to get in the best shape
of your life but you reach a whole new
demographic and the uh like a whole new
realm that you've never been able to hit
before and uh you get to fight other
creators and I think it's just the fact
I think we should get you a big area
honestly I've thought about a lot I want
to create an over 45 year old league for
boxing and I wanna you know because I'm
not looking to get in the ring with you
27 first of all you under 30 year olds
are starting to steroid out and you guys
are scare me with the 45 to 55 listen I
am willing to fight anybody who has an
audience who's over 45 and isn't
actually professionally capable of
fighting I'm ready because I I'd like to
knock someone the [ __ ] out just for like
the problem is if I get knocked the [ __ ]
out I'm not is self-esteemed out as I am
I'm not sure I can deal with on an
everyday basis seeing 800 memes of me
being knocked out so I have to focus on
this but I gotta tell you I'm open to it
see I think that'd be a lot of fun and I
think dads too if we start getting a lot
of the creators dads to go in the boxing
matches I don't know I think that'd be
pretty cool I I will tell you the boxing
thing is exactly right and the thing
that I'm looking to do is you know
you've got this huge pickleball match
coming up for tennis fans you know right
before the finals of March Madness with
John Mcenroe Andy Roddick Michael Chang
and Andre agassine I think that's going
to crush on ESPN a big one that I've
been trying to talk more about is
Pay-per-view one on one to 11 basketball
I think that you know boxing very
similarly two things stand out to me
running a race a hundred yard dash with
like five influencers like Olympic style
where you train for eight weeks and
one-on-one basketball I think would rate
heavy I think that if you and I played
one-on-one even with our small fan bases
that are big in the scheme of things
that would do better than people think
because there's there's something about
Mono Amano fighting is the ultimate
but you know something that a lot more
people would do is would play it's you
know I think a lot more people would do
the one-on-one thing and the race thing
so anyway I think you're on Austin
continued success brother hey thank you
for having me appreciate it thank you
everyone watching
all right I'm I think glitch am I
glitching out
yeah you're a little robotic which is
exciting to me because you were talking
about how everybody else was glitching
and now you're glitching and that makes
me know it really excited boxing thing
me out
all right Andrew you're still chopping
enough that I may have somebody else
might have to come in and introduce the
next person
Hannah you were always ready I'm here
everybody one of the great ways to build
a real organization I'm just going to
take a a little public service
announcement for people that want to
build meaningful things Hannah's worked
at Vena for nine years or so nine right
Hannah Help me nine and a half as I like
to say
um and as of a year ago 13 months ago
right you started in January of last
year is one of my chief of staffs I have
too and you know I think a lot of people
don't realize how much talent they have
in the building three six nine years in
that instead of doing what they do
bringing them more Inner Circle to help
you scale and here's another incredible
execution event needed somebody and boom
there she is as always Hannah thank you
you hate it
um next up we have Lauren Fritz Lauren
is the chief corporate Affairs and
marketing officer at wework and she's
all about creating Best in Class Global
team to deliver impact a lot of what
Gary was just saying now and listening
and learning from wework customers along
the way welcome Lauren thank you thank
you both for having me Lauren how are
you I'm great I really enjoyed the last
conversation because I think the AI
conversation is completely almost
opposite of what we're having because
we've had a front row seat to really
every company around the world and
listening to what they're thinking their
future work is so our insights are
coming directly from consumer from what
people are saying out there in the media
and social media so it's been a really
interesting learning for all of us over
the last few years really but honestly
you know as a company we've been doing
this from the beginning so
Lauren you know I'm I'm you know you
have some good lighting here so I'm I'm
not going to try to make you too red but
I really am passionate about more people
giving more people roses while they're
alive and active instead of like we're
all nice when it's all over and so you
know we've met recently and I have to
tell you I have the luxury of meeting so
many Chief marketing officers and CEOs
over the last 13 years and a very small
percentage do I leave the first meeting
saying oh they're really on it and I
just want you to know that that's how I
felt about you and so it's a real
pleasure and I'm actually genuinely
excited to hear what your hot takes are
for 2023 so let's not waste any more
time what what are the things that
you're most excited about or what are
you seeing
um well that was too kind of an
introduction I too feel the same about
you and your talent so I think you know
I really was what founded this company
was founded
um you know after the 2009 recession and
what's been interesting to see is back
then we might forget but there was this
sort of you know Reformation on the old
way of work
um and so when people think back then
like what was what happened then
obviously there was co-working obviously
there was other flexible space providers
we were not the first ones out there we
were the first brand to really connect
to what exactly people loved about their
work day and the connections you make
the people you're with and the spaces
we've created really enhanced that the
intentional design and people loved
showing up for each other and for their
job in wework spaces now over a decade
later we're dealing with the same thing
and I think you know what you read in
the news is that it feels like there's
this Reformation on you know the office
but in fact that's not actually really
what people are asking for they're
really asking for more control and
balance over their day so the listening
and learning we've developed over the
last really two years is enhancing our
product to create the ultimate
flexibility that really can set your
team up for success to how best they
want to work because it's not one size
fits all and I think like one of the hot
takes I would just say is reading over
the last few days everyone comes up with
their new idea like you have to shorten
your meetings less calendar invites less
people in meetings stand in meetings a
couple days a week
um but they're the one there's not one
thing that's going to solve for
everything and I think that's what
employees are asking for they're asking
for a holistic approach the one tip the
one you know time of day is not really
what they're looking for they're asking
for a full view of what you know how
they can best work in this hybrid world
and we think
I'm starting to interrupt but it's
exactly right like the biggest aha for
me like the amount of youngsters
especially that in the first couple
weeks of January where we have a hybrid
model of in office and out of office so
many of the kids were like reaching out
to me on email like oh [ __ ] I had no
idea how much I was missing like in one
day in the office I picked up on three
osmosis things that were incapable comma
we as Vayner are we worked out
actually have like offices out and
virtually out and I think it's a game of
and versus or I think people are so
obsessed I think all of our anxiety on
Earth is that people prefer or versus
and
I really do and I think this to your
point what got me excited to jump in is
the quicker everybody figures out it's
work from home and work from coffee shop
and have a wework in a street like the
way we use it is strategic markets right
like if and we kind of use it and and
we've used it a lot I mean we have our
core offices in wework we have strategic
little 10-person things there that works
along with being at home along with a
big HQ in certain parts of the world and
I think the quicker people fall in love
with and the quicker they're gonna get a
lot a lot of value right and our our you
know that's why last year we came out
with for all the ways you work we I
don't have the answer for you and I
think that's what everyone's figuring
out but what's been so interesting is
hearing from all sides of companies
every sector rethinking it and they're
really trying to take this more
intentional approach to what their work
day looks like what's interesting is
we're seeing over in um International
markets and Europe in particular people
really love coming back and there isn't
the same headlines as there are here and
I I think that's because you know
European culture has really had a
work-life balance built into the
structure of what their day-to-day is
like it's in nature of them in America
we're hustle harder we believed that
there was a time constraint into order
to say like you're doing a good job
because you're here early you stay late
like that we had a little more balance
and we're in the extremes right
generationally yeah and by the way
unlimited 25 year olds email like I've
had more kids under 30 email me saying
mandate everyone come back to the office
then I've had 50 or 40 year olds in my
company so this but but to your point
generationally obviously not everyone
culturally there is a certain segment
that has worked for 20 years that feels
everyone should come back that's too
extreme and then I have plenty of under
30 year olds who are like I don't want
to come into the office at all and I'm
like that's cool like we may want to
find someone
it's not a diabolical divide
if you read as I have every terminology
between what people are deciding is
their schedule remote first hybrid
there's still a place to come together
the most remote companies are still
saying to us hey we still want to get a
space to come together for our off-site
so now the on-site is the new off-site
like people want to come together for
the intentional collaboration they don't
want to be held to you know a set
schedule but if a set schedule works for
your team it might work for your team
there isn't one size to your point it's
and it's not either or and I think
there's space for everything and I think
that's what we just keep developing as
our product is really however you want
to fit in we're here to help you so for
all the ways you want to work and your
team is most successful we can help you
and lastly I'll just say I think with
the you know you know that unknown piece
people are surveying their teams they're
asking the questions they're trying to
do all the right things I think the good
intention is there but I don't think
they're getting the real insights that
they can you know most effectively get
outside of we have a new man I'm selling
you know management software solution
called wework workplace where like we
can help you analyze exactly how much
space you need because we've all had too
much space before the pandemic and how
do you best use it how your team is
telling you how they want to use it so
there's this data that creates a bond
and trust between the executives and
employees that is lacking right now so
wework really is in this really
interesting space Not only having the
benefit of listening to customers all
around the world of companies of all
sizes but we also have a suite of
products that no matter how you're
telling us you want to work we can help
you we can we can hook you up
Lauren thank you so much have the best
year thank you thanks for your support
that was a great conversation thank you
and one that could be like a two-hour
thing on itself right at Babs one of my
favorite marketers uh Ryan Harwood
Babs a whole lot too buddies of mine uh
said you know on-site is the new
off-site
right like call you know it was so crazy
because literally this morning going to
grabs a coffee I was like oh I might
just send this slack and tell everyone
to be here next Thursday just for fun
just for Vibes and that was exactly
what Babs was talking about there like
it's so wild how it flipped anyway I
don't know
um next we have Maureen Kelly she's the
CEO and founder of tarte Cosmetics
Maureen started tarte out over one
bedroom New York City Apartment we love
that hustle with a dream of developing
good for you beauty that's never boring
we're big fans of all the vegan products
that tarte has created
um and 20 years later she has built this
brand into a multi-million dollar
company welcome Maureen
you're a mute
you're on mute
that's like it seemed what you were
saying was profound and super exciting I
was hyped that's well you could just say
it again
I was saying yeah I started out of my
one bedroom apartment in New York and
Gary has been my online Mentor for 15
years he just we just haven't met yet
but I hear him on my ear all the time
it's an important commodity hustle
hustle hustle I mean so many business
decisions that I make I just hear him
saying don't worry don't don't worry
about being cringy don't worry about
rejection oh for 15 years
go for it I'm so happy for your success
morning you know you the brand is really
hitting its stride it's incredible to me
what over the last 12 months how much
it's hit the Lexicon more and more I
think much like a lot of things that
have worked for me I'm willing to be six
seven twelve years early and let it come
to me I think you're a real example of
that so for me it's just actually very
interesting to see what your hot takes
are for 2023 so fire away what are you
seeing what are you focused on what do
you what do you what do you like yeah uh
all about you know just keeping pivoting
right and I think that's you're the king
of that so just keeping moving obviously
um influencer marketing has been really
big for us and we do it in a really
cheap and cheerful way so we do it not
by just doing paid influencer marketing
but we do it through relationships so
for us it's not about saying like Okay
here we're going to pay you to just do
an ad for us like we get face to face
with them
um and meet them and interact with them
and get them to know what we're all
about which is you know very much like
you know lifting up women and um you
know giving back that's been a really
big part of my DNA since 1999. oh my
gosh I can't even believe it's been that
long sometimes like you know the 24
years and sometimes it feels like
yesterday
um and then I would say the other thing
is just you know just keeping to try new
things right I mean I feel like you know
I mean you're on the heels of one right
now right you had a real moment with
this Dubai execution I feel like
there haven't been a lot of people that
have innovated on influencer marketing
in the last three years I think people
have done things around the edges but
maybe you can explain to the audience
like what I'm referring to how and
what's been the aftermath because I
think you really had a moment yeah yeah
and you know so we've been doing
influencer trips since I mean for the
past I would say nine years
um you know we've been taking
influencers everywhere from like to my
home here in the Florida Keys after like
the hurricane to you know build like
storm kits and things like that's a Bora
Bora back in the day and now just
recently like you're saying Gary to
Dubai and this past trip really took off
in a big way and we've got a lot of
great feedback both other feedback
um but you know the key for us was the
other feedback like it's too glitzy and
glamor like what was the count what were
people's like what do they want to make
of it
said you know it was a female
empowerment trip you know we um have
been selling in the UAE for seven years
and so we brought all of these like
really powerful like creative smart
women there and we donated to a UAE
charity that lifts up um young girls and
so some people said you didn't bring any
boys on the trip but it was a female
empowerment trip some people said you
didn't bring um can we can we just all
agree that 2023 should be the year of
like it's super okay to have a girls
trip it's super okay to have a boys trip
even though I know I know boys have had
it better but like is it not okay can we
say that it's okay to have a sports trip
or like a spa like can we just get to a
place of like everyone on Earth all
agreeing that everyone's a [ __ ]
hypocrite because for whatever they try
to cancel they're doing some [ __ ] that
someone else is going to cancel can we
just see this morning can we just can we
just speed this the [ __ ] up all be
canceled to be uncanceled to reset the
whole thing I love every the my right
friends I have unlimited friends on both
sides oh the left's too sensitive you
got mad about Eminem's like everyone's a
sensitive everyone's like the hypocrisy
in society is [ __ ] that's my hot take
for 2023. more [ __ ] hypocrisy that the
entire world is trading now there's not
one [ __ ] me included here that's like
that's not good that then you do an hour
late or something that is completely
pissing someone off everyone sucks
everyone's good can we just [ __ ]
enough and we're all doing our best drop
the freaking mic people were saying why
not 100 of people are doing their best
and by the way the numbers up down to 98
because it used to be one percent bad
now it's two percent because people are
just so [ __ ] tired on the extreme
left they're extreme right and it's
making people go more [ __ ] extreme
and like what the [ __ ] like keep your
feet to yourself it doesn't [ __ ] yeah
then they're saying we were tone deaf
because we spend so much money we got
every single thing you're allowed to
you're allowed to spend money on what
you want to spend I think every brand
that runs a [ __ ] commercial on TV is
wasting money
I would much rather take [ __ ]
influences to Dubai than buy a [ __ ]
commercial on the AFC Championship game
that that one [ __ ] person watched
yeah and we got to spend the week with
them we got to know them we got to talk
about the things that are important to
us got to put the products on their
faces then they said that we didn't
bring people that were my age and I was
hypocrite for that everything's a
problem ageism youthism like like
everything's a problem
yeah it was it was a lot everyone had
feedback on everything but I want
everybody know it's on both [ __ ]
sides you [ __ ] like everyone was like
yeah yeah no no
enough
the moms don't count the moms don't
count I was like wait why the moms not
count because they're these like
gorgeous amazing
every single thing is bad if you decide
to take a snapshot
right like like why don't we look at the
whole picture why don't we look at the
company's 365 days of activities yes
it's so true it is so true but it was
the most amazing trip it went viral
everyone was saying we made no sales for
which we made so much money for it and
then people were saying that I fired my
marketing team I'm like what I came in
Monday morning and I was like wait what
in the world you know everyone has
something to say for everything but I
have to say it was truly incredible we
had all these amazing female founded
um products that got donated on the trip
so everything that we gave was free and
we were supporting all these cool like
entrepreneurial brands on the trip so it
was just it was a really great viral
moment that took off in the best kind of
way without some well we got two minutes
what else like what are you seeing on
Tick Tock what are you seeing on YouTube
what about YouTube shorts give me a
little LinkedIn have you done LinkedIn
marketing yet like talk to me I spend 10
minutes a night because of you on linked
on my own LinkedIn
um you know I forced myself I land but
at night and I'm liking people's posts
and I posted on my LinkedIn before I
came on this to say like hey guys tune
in I mean this is a bucket list moment
for me and I created my own okay so 24
years of having a brand I've never had
my own personal socials ever not
Facebook not on Instagram nothing and I
just this summer created a tech talk
because you know I put your um your
podcast on when I'm brushing my teeth
you know doing my makeup in the morning
I listen to it in like 15 minutes like
segments you know all the way through to
the end go for my hot girl walks you
know just you know you get it in and
like you know you chop it up and I felt
like you know I listened to everything
you say but then you say develop your
own personal brand and that's one thing
I never did so I launched my own Tech
and my I have teenage boys and they were
like oh my God Mom you're so cringy this
is awful all our friends from high
school are like and I have to say it's
been growing and it's been really fun
and you know I started overthinking the
concept in the beginning I was like you
know delete delete no I can't post this
and now I'm like f it I just film it the
ones that I took for 10 seconds I put up
like they're going my room and it's so
fun I love it and there's nothing more
fun than razzing your teenage Sons
that's the ROI of the whole thing just
forget about if anything good happens
for business just getting the guns in
check a little bit is a little fun too
right especially because the girls in
their schools were like oh my gosh it's
so cool right yeah once they realize
that you might actually lead to be a
gateway to some hooking up they're gonna
love you for it right now they're like
Mom you suck and then all of a sudden
like some girl in school that they
really like thinks you're cool they're
gonna be like wait a minute totally I'm
like I'm cool I'm like the ultimate
wingman to your boys this is like a
[ __ ] massive strategy
the only time they asked me for makeup
is if they're like you know getting like
a d or like a c like for a teacher I'm
like oh my God they're like why can't
you have sort of like a kiteboarding
company or something cool like makeup is
cool
it is cool
I'm really happy for you continued
success really thank you so much
it is cool
Harry if I can tell you something
Maureen has the biggest heart she came
in to our briefing session with Summer
with this wide open heart and by the way
she started filming content during the
briefing she's the first one out in like
three years that's done that just love
you
continued success
thank you
thank you
and thank you Gary
oh Hannah
I'm back
Hannah's back I'm out so everybody thank
you for being on with me great try today
Andrea
um that was a fun Hannah that was a fun
session it was really fun and very hot
takes were were sad I have decided you
know this because you've been in
meetings with me I've like I [ __ ]
have a bleeding heart I [ __ ] love
everybody it's really like a disease and
my superpower
but like enough judgment on each other
it's just enough [ __ ] in Christ yeah as
if people can't look in the mirror and
see they're doing the same thing
let judgment be the best teacher
every single person here is doing dumb
[ __ ] and everyone's doesn't want to
they're just trying
anyway love you see you later thanks for
joining us
um and next up we welcome Gallery media
groups Chief Revenue officer Chris
Anthony to interview our next guest Doug
zarkin Doug is a CMO of Pearl Vision and
runs their Global Optical franchise
business his work with this team has won
the entrepreneur media top 500 franchise
brand Awards and is currently the
subject of a Harvard Business School
case study on brand Rejuvenation welcome
Doug and Chris
what's up I'm a little bummed I mean
Gary's background's probably the only
time I've ever been on a zoom call where
where it looks more like a sports bar
than mine so dueling background I love
it we'll have to take snap grabs yes and
following that one we have a big the bar
set High sure good to see you Doug um
excited to dig into this and get your
take on all things 2023.
um but yeah we have 10 minutes or a lot
to get into I'm gonna run through a
bunch of topics that I know you'll have
an awesome hot take for 23. kicking off
um dni inclusivity you know it's
becoming much much bigger requirement
and conversation for all of us marketers
how do you see that approaching 23 and
how are you approaching that as well
you know when you when you used use the
the phrase Dei you immediately go to
race
um and I think as as a child who's
entered the phase of parenting their
parents I'm I'm embarrassed and appalled
by the way Brands and businesses treat
seniors
um and ironically one of the emphasis
that we're placing is on the dynamic of
Gen X having to care for their parents
um I also think is the parent of kids
the way in which marketers go about
trying to engage with parents especially
with younger kids is really challenging
and for us at Pearl Vision you know we
want to be I care for for the entire
family and so we're making a real effort
to lean hard into both marketing to
engage seniors in a healthy dialogue to
bring their business in but also letting
parents know about things like the
undiagnosed Vision issues of kids one
out of four school-aged kids have an
undiagnosed Vision issue it's incredible
and most kids that have an undiagnosed
Vision issue are susceptible to being
diagnosed
incorrectly with a learning disability
so we want to lean into helping parents
be their version of their best parent by
just educating and informing letting
them know that we're here
love that and it feels like you guys are
just such a perfect brand to your point
to be able to really serve that entire
sort of family of customers that you
guys have all the time so yeah love
that's such an important topic uh
Switching gears for a second obviously
we're just coming off the heels of CES
we know there's so much conversation
around Ai and chat GPT and just Tech
overall
um in our world how are you thinking
about technology it's really better
those customers that you guys have yeah
you know so 10 years ago it was the the
nonsense of Amazon was killing retail
Amazon didn't kill retail Amazon killed
shitty retail it made retailers really
understand the importance of experience
and now you hear technology is going to
replace human interaction and I couldn't
be couldn't be less true what technology
for us at Pearl does is actually allow
us to deliver a better experience and
that's because in things like digital
measurements which allow us to ensure
that your glasses are fit perfectly for
your face because there's like five
percent of the world that has a
perfectly symmetrical face and so
digital measurements allow us to
actually create a really personalized
pair of glasses for you lens simulator
allows you to actually see what you're
buying in a way that allows you to
understand the commitment that you're
making and why the better lenses are
good for you so we look at it as a way
to just do a better job in caring for
the person behind the eyes and leaving
them with a great pair of glasses they
can be excited about so great yeah I
feel like there's so much innovation in
health technology and the stuff that the
work that you guys are doing is just
really remarkable and to your point it
just makes the customers experience so
much stronger
hope so in that same breath um 23 we're
in this now there's so much predictions
around the economy what that's going to
mean for us as marketers and how we're
approaching it how are you what's your
take and how are you thinking about 23
maybe differently or the same for the
brand
man
um I wish I could produce predict the
future you know in the absence of having
that crystal ball and certainly I'm not
Nostradamus we are really focusing on
the must do's and the need to do's and
and by that I mean the things that
absolutely are going to allow us to
achieve plan and really connect with our
consumers then we get into like the
goods and the shoulds and and those are
things that are perhaps opportunities
maybe not low hanging fruit but
potentially allow us the opportunity to
grow even faster and for that it's
really about putting it carefully into
our brand DNA filter and understanding
you know is it going to allow us to
forge a stronger connection is it going
to allow us to recruit patients is it
going to allow us to to build business I
don't necessarily think 23 is the year
for the for the wants and the nice to
haves
um at least not at this point you know
certainly if the first six months of
this year turn out to be strong for all
of us then we're absolutely going to
open the door we we have a lock box at
Pearl
um to use an old phrase that we keep
some money in allows us to be
opportunistic of something comes up or
maybe something that we want to try I
mean one of the things I'm super proud
of is that the way our team is
structured a good idea can go from
anyone and anywhere and so we absolutely
Avail ourselves the opportunity to take
a good idea from a member of the team
and bring it forward but I think we're
cautiously optimistic in January has
been pretty good to us love that
building on that you know there's the
whole sort of constant balance and
potentially struggle of Performance
Marketing versus brand marketing how do
you think about that as a leader and how
should anybody really think about that
in this year so to pull a garyvee holy
[ __ ] please stop please stop bifurcating
performance in a brand so here's the
thing Performance Marketing is great you
show up on page one of Google to use an
example that's wonderful but if your
brand doesn't mean anything you're not
going to generate the response that you
want just like doing great ads that
motivate consumers if it doesn't
motivate consumers to take action then
it's just pretty words on paper or
pretty pictures and so the real skill of
today's CMO is being able to bring both
the performance and a mindset together
and figuring out that intersection if
you start to separate one from the other
what you may have is is using the seven
layer cake analogy a cake that doesn't
taste great mm-hmm and that's what a
marketing plan is it's a seven layer
cake of different steps to get people
down into the funnel to hopefully
deliver the results you want to deliver
I love that and to that point you know
we know that you know Finding sort of
that consumer or customer you know is
becoming so Diversified there's so many
platforms out there now there's so much
consumer attention figuring out where
that is how do you and how do the brand
think about the platforms overall in the
mix where are you spending time where
should where's where's the difference in
previous years from a platforms you know
this is where the Art and Science comes
into marketing
um you know there are there are
foundational elements to our plan and
and I want to keep those kind of close
to the chest but what I will say is you
know between privacy regulations and
some other changes in the digital
ecosystem you know we're having to take
a couple steps backwards in order to
take a step forward when it comes to
where our investments are you know one
thing I'm really proud of is our
continued commitment to local
um provision is a brand that was built
in the neighborhood started by a
neighborhood doctor and the success of
our franchisees is in that connection
with the neighborhood so we're actually
looking at a lot of offline tools a lot
of old school tools we have this program
called cornea which basically supports
our our franchisees going on in the
community and doing Vision screenings
and I work cleaning and adjustments it's
really an opportunity for our neighbors
to meet the people behind the eyes the
people that are caring for them in their
in their neighborhood eye care center
and it's an incredibly successful and
lucrative platform pre-covered I mean we
were generating about 20 patients per
every event and these are small events
it's a Friday night life football game
it's showing up at a church or synagogue
it's just being a part of the community
and it's allowed us to remain sticky you
know what's old is new again I think
you're hearing a lot about Brands going
back into the world of direct mail
because we've done such an awful job at
being disciplined with um the way in
which we use email I mean how many
emails do you get a day yeah um so we're
having to look a lot of offline tools to
complement our online tools but I'm
super excited about some of the progress
that we're seeing in really being able
to localize our marketing well that last
question I think this probably feeds
exactly into that the whole neighborhood
mentality of the brand what sort of just
your take on you know there's so much
going on in the world so much going on
in Australia and sort of just the
humanization of marketing what does that
mean to you and what do you think that
that should mean to the audience for 23.
you know
marketers used to be asked you know how
do you you know are you a data driven
marker and you know I'm a firm believer
that data doesn't make decisions data
helps to inform the decisions that a
marketer makes and because a marketer
has to look at their target audience
more than just a set of numbers on an
Excel chart we have to understand the
emotions the attributes the feelings the
perceptions what's the narrative going
on in the head of our consumer what's
the psychographic and that combined with
the data allows you to make really good
strategic bets I mean look a brand
marketer would love to say they know
their target audience better than they
know themselves and that just isn't the
case to be successful you got to be
humble you have to be arrogant a bit to
think that you can actually get into the
mind of a consumer and motivate them to
take the action you want them to take
when you want them to take it but at the
same time you have to be humble and
realize that the only way to lead a
brand successfully with a consumer is to
listen first and you know when you're a
franchise system like Pearle Vision with
nearly 600 Eye Care Centers in North
America you have a built-in pipeline for
Consumer feedback you have a built-in
pipeline to understand if you're doing
what's working and what's not and most
importantly you're constantly assessing
the behaviors of your consumer to figure
out how you can best serve them provide
them value and doing that through really
in our case you know caring about the
person behind the eyes
love that such such a great sort of take
on 23 it sounds like you're embodying
that as a leader and the brand as well
um Doug this was super great such great
hot take for 23. good luck to you and
the brand excited to see all this stuff
in motion and all the success around
that thanks for having me
thanks you guys that was awesome
Chris I love having you on this show
thanks for having me it's always great
excited we're already a month into 23
lots of good stuff happening can you
believe it more and more and more let's
bring it on all right
we'll see you soon we're gonna bring
Nick miritus up next Nick
Andrea hello hello hello what's up can
you hear me are you there can you hear
me now I know I'm in and out I'm in and
out I'm feeling a tremendous amount of
Love today though this like this show is
fire okay Miss Hannah for jumping in
let's see let's see if I can uh kick
this one off so guess what we're gonna
bring Kate Brady up next she's the
senior director she's in charge of next
gen d2c at PepsiCo and Kate and her team
are focused on delivering meaningful
consumer experiences through direct to
Consumer engagement thanks for joining
us Kate
what is going on how you doing I am
great thanks so much for having me it's
been a great session so far I think you
might have the coolest job at PepsiCo
been thinking about this
I've been really fortunate I've I've had
some really amazing jobs at PepsiCo and
each one just seems to get better so
really thrilled oh my goodness all right
well this one at least 10 minutes always
go really fast so let's start out with I
think we're gonna go into the hot take
realm of all things web three yeah
future of d2c like this is a big topic
so viewers out there don't know Pepsi
has really been trailblazing in this
space lots of innovative programs I mean
almost from like the earliest moments of
when everybody started talking about all
things web3
um so maybe share a little bit on the
opener here about pepsico's journey I
mean we've had free mints on Pepsi we've
had Gatorade with some really nice
charitable benefit stuff we've had
Cheetos in the metaverse
um they just give a little background to
the viewers and then we'll uh we'll chop
it up yeah Nick so I'm I'm thanks for
calling it out and I'm really really
proud about how PepsiCo puts Innovation
at the Forefront of everything that
we're doing and for the past few years
I've really been focused on driving
Innovation across the organization and
the line I would always talk about is
identifying what's new what's next and
the best way for us to connect with our
consumers that was that's always been my
role and it's evolved into this one now
um and I loved you know Gary's hot take
about blowing up about buying it was
just a little hot
I loved it though because it really does
Drive what we're trying to accomplish
here is we recognize that this whole
landscape is becoming so much more
fragmented and challenged and if we want
to really connect with our consumers
especially those younger audiences in
meaningful ways moving forward we have
to innovate the way that we're doing
those connections and we see web3 as a
real big driver for doing that
um you know we want to be at the
Forefront of culture but also like
driving culture when we can and and so
you know to remain relevant we see
whether he is a key enabler and so we've
been exploring a number of different
tools within this space
um and as you mentioned we've been
executing a number of different Pilots
many in partnership with the V3 team
have been awesome partners and over the
past six months we've been standing up
what we're calling our web 3 Center of
enablement
um but our work began about a year ago a
little over a year ago and our our first
draft was actually in partnership with
Vayner and Todd Kaplan and our Pepsi
brand team dropped the first generative
of art nft collection and from there we
really haven't stopped
um you mentioned the the digital
collectible space that we've been
leaning into from Gatorade perspective
we did this awesome partnership where um
or a collection where our player of the
year activation which is something where
we're
um awarding you know top high school
athletes across the globe this time we
were able to commemorate them and
memorialize them with their own digital
collectible and as a part of that we
tied it to a charitable donation so all
primary and secondary sales are a
portion of those was going to this
amazing organization called
goodsports.inc so it was a way for us to
really Drive philanthropic goals as well
as like connecting with these new
consumers and doing this awesome
activation
um you mentioned like the Horizon worlds
activation where we did with Cheetos
this purely virtual experience where we
were bringing the the ethos of what
Cheetos is all about and that Mischief
nature and this Halloween activation
where you were able to play in this
virtual graveyard type of space and
resurrect new flavors that in real life
you were actually resurrecting some old
I think it was chipotle ranch Cheetos
got brought back to life based on this
activation which is awesome
um but we also done you know parallels
to
um virtual in real life experiences like
what we did with do and decentraland and
Call of Duty subliner team where we did
um we mirrored what was going on in
Brooklyn and at the Kings theater we had
this Esports competition going on where
we did a parallel experience but much
more immersive and engaging with these
games and sweepstakes into Central land
that was really a great way to just
enhance what we're doing and that's what
I love about web3 is that you can do so
much more than what you can do in the
real life because the sky's the limit on
the capabilities but so over the past
six months we've done almost 15
different separate activations across
you know across the globe so I work
across all markets All Brands and
everyone's really excited to lean in so
right now you know they're smaller
efforts we're testing and learning but
right now is the time to lean in
understand like what's working what's
not and continue to grow from those
activations and so I'm really proud of
what we've accomplished in that pretty
relatively short time
I mean and it seems like it's just
speeding up right yeah
becomes exponential and and generally
speaking the excitement level when you
see these things go live it's just so
cool because it all feels like it's
never been done before
um so in terms of Fortune 500 you know
PepsiCo I think like the the scale at
which PepsiCo operates is so awesome on
so many levels what should you know
Fortune 500 companies might be watching
be asking themselves about web 3 in
general you know what should the
conversation be if they haven't gotten
into you know having an approach yet
like where start by starting how do you
get going yeah um great question and I
think for us you know some of the key
questions we're always asking is what's
a specific use case or applications that
align to our business goals and
objectives this shouldn't just be about
driving PR or Buzz for us we see this as
a huge unlock for um helping Drive first
party data acquisition so that's been a
priority for us as we move forward
another is really about like how do we
incorporate the technology into our
existing systems and processes so make
it really more of a seamless
frictionless integration
um how do we stay ahead of the curve in
terms of web 3 adoption and Innovation
you know for our for us our position is
by building the capabilities internally
um it will yield significant dividends
in the future versus US waiting back
seeing how it all works out and then
trying to catch up but at the same time
we're also as we're building those
internal capabilities we're also
building and forming tons of new
Partnerships like what we've done with
V3 that help us leverage you know really
driving the accelerated approach
um one of the biggest challenges that
we've faced today which I think is so
important is just how do you ensure
sickness security and compliance with
the regulations as you're implementing
these web3 Tech so for us I have spent
more time with our Securities Law team
than I've ever imagined I would before
um but it's it's really important at
this point you know when you're facing
everything against 1933 written
Securities laws you have a lot of
discussion and debate to try and figure
out how are we actually structuring
ourselves to to comply with these
current these existing regulations so
you know we are hopeful that there will
be some Forest regulation especially
with what you know the crazy
everything that happened with FTX over
the summer and all what we've seen
lately it's horrible but at the same
token we're hoping that that helps Drive
some more regulation in the future
um you know when we think about our
approach it's it's really about
um it has to include doing research and
staying informed on what the latest
developments in this Tech is you know
this is such a massive task is how new
the space is
um but education is really top of my
list of like what the approach should be
moving forward because you need to take
your key stakeholders along in this
journey
um you know we talked about the use
cases I think that from an approach
perspective just ensuring that you have
the applications that's aligning with
your goals
um building a team that and working with
external Partners both internally and
externally I'm sure if you ask anyone in
any sort of Fortune 500 company you're
going to find a ton of people raising
their hand to say hey I want to help
this is amazing I want to get involved
um so lean let them lean in and help
your agendas your developer helping out
those capabilities and for us you know
testing and piloting has been critical
to doing this and so we've done a number
of these proofs of concept or Pilots to
deliver on these hypotheses that we've
had and this like I said is the time to
test and learn I think that you know
it's going to be accepted a lot better
now than if you're failing five years
from now and really don't understand the
space so this is where we get a little
bit more time to work out the Kinks
nice um let's try and squeeze one or two
more in real quick so hot take here
um jumping around off the back of that
what opportunities do you see in the
world of web 3 and and knowing your role
in terms of rewards loyalty program the
future of d2c I think you have such a
cool front row seat to really continue
to lead there so hot takes for 23. where
are we going
we um you know I think where we started
with our web3 approach to where we are
now
that's really shifted um and where
initially we were focused on like hey
how are we using this to drive new net
revenue streams I think we've evolved to
like how are we using this to drive
deeper more meaningful engagement with
our consumers and these new audiences
building communities how are we
leveraging it from a utility perspective
and really how can this help enable a
more a better uh rewards loyalty
platform type of um program so that's
where we've really pivoted our approach
of away from just you know there might
be future opportunities from a revenue
perspective for us though it's really
about what utility can this offer and
helping Drive deeper and more immersive
experiences more meaningful consumer
engagement and then helping us drive our
Loyalty Rewards platform you know this
is something of a huge priority for us
because we see that this can enable
um from you know it can help us enable
more engaging rewarding customer loyalty
programs in a more efficient transparent
and secure nature than we've ever seen
in the web 2 spot that's so cool all
right last one real quick before they
they kick us off here
um I I can I bet people watching right
now are like wow web3 I wonder where did
I start so knowing you've been on this
journey what are the resources the
go-to's you know the YouTube channels
the podcast where do you go to get
inspired to get information about the
space yeah
ton of podcasts um that's really been my
source of information I've read a few
books I found you know I think it's it's
so hard because it's so new and there's
so much more new information coming out
books I feel like are really hard to
lean into because it's how does it get
published it'll be relevant
um but like Kathy Hackle is an amazing
resource just listening to her podcast
the web3 academy has been a great
resource just from an education
perspective
um things like um Anderson's Horowitz uh
web3 with eight six uh a16z has been
great
um welcome to the metaverse uh there's
so many out there if you just put in
web3 or metaverse into you know the
search engine a tunnel pop up and I
found so much value like just listening
to a few of them even things like web
2.5 I think you know that approach of
how we're evolving from web 2 to web3
loving that take on things on these
companies that are on similar Journeys
is what we're doing so huge resource um
opportunity to just listen in and learn
from from these experiences nice I get
some homework to do this weekend
it was basically for me thank you so
much
um can be proud of the partnership we're
building
um and just so excited to show the world
soon some new stuff too so stay tuned
thank you so much awesome Hannah's back
no Andrea yeah thanks Nick
um and last but not least I have the
honor of chatting with the amazing
Lindsay Kaplan Lindsay is the co-founder
and chief brand officer of Chief and if
you're not already familiar familiar
with what Chief is it is the most
powerful network of women Executives in
the world she's been named one of
Business Insider's most Innovative CMOS
in the world and one of at age's leading
women and I really cannot wait to chat
with her today I know we've had a couple
of chats but welcome Lindsay thanks
Hannah how are you I'm good I'm excited
to chat with you good all the hot takes
it is a lot of hot takes that we've had
um but before we get started can you
just give us your Founder's story and
what really inspired chief sure so Chief
came from a really personal place
um I had actually prior to Chief been
working at a startup it was a hot D to
see New York City startup that everybody
knew I was the first full-time employee
and as that company grew I became one of
the few women in leadership and I also
pretty quickly got pregnant and so I was
juggling this Paradox of first of all as
you're a female leader your decisions
have outsized impact so you already have
the challenges of knowing what it is to
be a leader and knowing that you're
representing all of the women because
they're looking up to you at the top but
then I also needed to put together my
own mat leave policy and so I felt like
there was this personal need as a leader
that I really wanted a community of
other women who were at that executive
level who understood that you know we
have a lot of different challenges and a
lot of bias going up against us and so
there's a Vanishing Act of resources for
women at the top wouldn't it be great to
really collect all of these incredible
women and put them into one great
Network that's really incredible and so
you really you've already kind of hit on
this but can you tell us what is so
special about the community at Chief
um and even get a little bit into what
did you learn during covid and the
pandemic
oh I learned to be very thankful for my
nanny well let me take a step I can tell
you a little bit about what makes Chief
different so there are a lot of
organizations out there for leadership
and there are a lot of women's
organizations and what we found is that
they're really verticalized so I had
been a part of you know women in
advertising there's women in marketing
and what generally happens is the women
Executives in those organizations become
the de facto mentors right so all of a
sudden where do the mentors go for
co-mentorship so again we created this
um private Network that has criteria so
that you are with other members who get
it who are at that level of leadership
so right now 77 of Fortune 100 companies
have a chief member in their leadership
teams and collectively Chief members
control 800 billion dollars of the
global economy so this is a really
special Network and it is incredibly
powerful
that's amazing
um and you know I can speak to what we
learned during the pandemic which you
mentioned which is that when when times
are tough those times hit women harder
yeah and so we've seen two things the
first is that the pandemic really
accelerated the need to make sure that
women and marginalized people are
supported right because they're the
first people that end up leaving the
workforce during uh times when Child
Care is in limbo it also really
reinforced the need for community so we
were all isolated we're all alone we're
all working from home that is when we
need each other more right that is when
you really need to find a community and
a network of people who can be there and
to support you
that's amazing
um knowing that you are and you've
created this really beautiful community
of high-powered female Executives what
are the current topics those leaders are
talking about what is important for them
as they look ahead into this new year
well we're constantly evolving our
programming and right now we're paying a
lot of attention to the impact of global
economic headwinds so we've done a lot
to support our members because some of
them are making decisions related to the
economy some of them are having to enact
layoffs and other people are the victims
of layoffs so we set up our career
transition group we have speakers like
executive coach Susan peppercorn and we
have a lot of workshops around
navigating the downturn
that's amazing
um
this is a little bit different but a lot
of organizations right now I think in
particular as we're going into this
hybrid work mode
um are struggling with how to build
cultures and communities that are
relevant for the current climate that
we're in what would you share with our
community of leaders on what they should
be thinking and doing
so I think it's about making sure that
we're being thoughtful around inclusive
workplace practices so when you think
about back to work women are 25 more
likely to accept a job that's remote
because they have caregiving
responsibilities by and large on top of
generally what their counterparts have
so we need to think about what do the
policies look like Beyond just parental
leave and mat leave but what are we
doing to implement a culture in our
organizations that is mindful of
caregiving that is thoughtful about
flexible hours
are we doing a four day work week for
certain individuals what is a part-time
schedule look like why do people need to
go back to the office every single day
um these are all really important uh
pieces of the puzzle that help create a
better environment for marginalized
people and women love that
um any hot takes for 2023 I love the
four day work week that you kind of just
snuck in there but uh whatever it's a
good one yeah at Chief we have a four
and a half day work week so we do half
day Fridays we started it during the
pandemic and we realized our team was
incredibly productive and really needed
that time Friday afternoon to run
errands go to doctor's appointments have
time off just to relax so huge fan of
the four or four and a half day work
week
um hot takes is that companies that
don't continue to invest in Dei in 2023
will have their butts handed to them in
2024. so we are seeing uh companies now
step up put their money where their
mouth is and invest in Dei programs it's
the right thing to do and it's also
going to make your company Stronger Yeah
I mean it's massive so many companies
took a big pledge in 2020 and 2021 and
it really is time to deliver against
those things exactly
um anything else you want to share in
like our last minute to two minutes here
anything about if anything about
yourself
yeah I think that we are seeing uh the
need again to support senior women we're
seeing women dropping out across the
pipeline but particularly as they get
into these manager to director positions
and then again that director through
c-suite and so when we think about what
we want to do to support women to make
sure that companies are really striving
towards gender Equity within their their
organizations we have to think about
supporting the women who are in these
positions of power because we put them
on a pedestal we ask them to do their
job really well and to carry the extra
burdens the third shift of mentoring
speaking on panels speaking up for
Progressive workplace policies and those
women need to be supportive so we're
really excited that we just rolled out
our Enterprise offering and so now
companies can come directly to chief and
work with us on nominating women in
their executive level positions so shout
out to some incredible companies that
have partnered with us already like
United Healthcare IBM yum brands uh big
companies that are stepping up and
really want to make sure they're doing
the right thing
um and supporting the executive women on
their teams
that is really incredible Lindsay thank
you so much for sharing all of your
insights on Chief and um you know I I
would love to get involved someday I've
heard some I I mentioned this in our
first conversation but I've just heard
some really incredible personal stories
from friends of mine who have had
amazing experiences with Chief the
community there the network aspect which
I think you actually don't get enough in
different Club club-like organizations
um and so the fact that you guys are
thinking about programming for the
recession and whatnot you know in a
really smart and impactful way is is
just massive so kudos to you and the
whole team achieve thanks Hannah there's
a membership spot open for you whenever
you're ready amazing
way to close out the show you guys that
was that was incredible really deep and
and really important thank you so much
and a special thanks to Miss Hannah
we've got people in the in the comments
that are like bring her back bring her
back I'm always here guys here for me
you're always there for everybody
I'm just glad that my internet like was
able to like power on so I could I could
come on live and just give you a big hug
I love it it's rallying one more time
for us yeah close it out
thank you Hannah all right and thanks
everyone for joining the show today
we've got another show coming up that's
actually on AI which has been a big
topic of conversation today so please
join us on March 6th for that episode
from 12 until 1 eastern time thanks
everybody and we'll see you very soon
check out um or please feel free to send
on the recording to your friends and
family you can check us out on mftn for
marketing for the now.vaynerx.com
see you soon